Hi, I'm Ray, I'm one of the co-organizers of this conference. For me, it was the best one so far. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. If we're going to throw the word princess around, it only is applied to you, buddy. Has been released at C++ Under the Sea. It's called Parrot. It's the best Kuda C++ experience out there. Template parameter, a non-type template parameter that's like an ant. Like you have a function that takes a scanning scan.
嗨，我是 Ray，我是这次会议的共同组织者之一。对我来说，这是目前为止最棒的一次。哇，哇，哇，哇。如果我们非要用“公主”这个词，那也只能用在你身上，伙计。它已经在 C++ Under the Sea 上发布了。它叫 Parrot。它是目前市面上最好的 CUDA C++ 体验。模板参数，一种像蚂蚁一样的非类型模板参数。就像你有一个函数，它接受一个扫描。
De-couple of look-back scan, naturally. The inclusive scan is... I assume you've read the Dwayne Merrill. paper. Did we originally say what you work at invidia for like two more days? Paul doesn't work at invidia anymore. Yeah no he doesn't work in video anymore. Sorry Paul. This is the scan man. That is what you should be known as. Bryce the scan man. Adelstein Lelbeck. Yes. on October 10th, 2025. My name is Connor.
自然是解耦回溯扫描。包含扫描是……我假设你读过 Dwayne Merrill 的论文。我们之前是不是说你在英伟达还要再工作两天？Paul 不在英伟达工作了。是的，他不在这儿工作了。抱歉，Paul。这就是“扫描侠”。这就是你应该被称为的名字。Bryce，“扫描侠”。Adelstein Lelbeck。是的。2025 年 10 月 10 日。我叫 Connor。
Today with my co-host, Bryce. We record once again live from the Netherlands the second time and second year in a row we attended C++ Under the Sea. In this episode, we'll be talking to two different invidians, Ray and Paul, about the new Parrot Library and also about
今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 在一起。我们再次在荷兰进行现场录制，这是我们连续第二年参加 C++ Under the Sea。在这一集中，我们将与两位英伟达员工 Ray 和 Paul 谈谈新的 Parrot 库，以及
scans. Here we go, folks. We'll redo that. C++ live from Breda, Netherlands. C++ Under the C-C-25, second edition. It's not the inaugural one, folks. We recorded here.
扫描。开始了，各位。我们要重录一遍。C++ 现场直播，地点荷兰布雷达。C++ Under the Sea 25，第二届。这不是首届，各位。我们在这里录制。
But, but, this year, we are here as founding sponsors. Well, we're here for NVIDIA as founding sponsors. We had a booth. We had a bunch of NVIDIA people here. Therefore, we are founding sponsors of C++ under the sea. Day 2 just wrapped. We're about to talk to Sean, probably a couple other folks. and we were going to record last night.
但是，但是，今年我们是以创始赞助商的身份来到这里的。好吧，我们是作为英伟达的创始赞助商来到这里的。我们有一个展位。我们有一群英伟达的人在这里。因此，我们是 C++ Under the Sea 的创始赞助商。第二天刚刚结束。我们正要和 Sean 谈谈，可能还有其他几个人。我们本来打算昨晚录制的。
Today is October 10th. Bryce was too tired. Dinner ended at like 10.30. Admittedly dinner did go on for a while. If we had recorded dinner, there were some Sean stories that I've never heard before, and they were some top quality. Let us tease and make the listener feel bad, folks. Was it his best story?
今天是 10 月 10 日。Bryce 太累了。晚餐在 10 点半左右结束。诚然，晚餐确实持续了一段时间。如果我们录下了晚餐，里面有一些我从未听过的 Sean 的故事，而且质量极高。让我们卖个关子，让听众感到遗憾吧，伙计们。那是他最好的故事吗？
I don't know. But it was... Like to do the two or three stories may have been the best storytelling. Oh, God. I mean, all of Sean's stories are great. I've heard a lot of them. He's a storyteller that. And I hadn't heard, I think, two of the three that he told last night.
我不知道。但它……就像那两三个故事可能是最好的叙事。天哪。我的意思是，Sean 的所有故事都很棒。我听过很多。他就是那样一个讲故事的人。而且我想，他昨晚讲的三个故事里有两个我没听过。
And one of them, I was just like, my God. Which one? The Photoshop 4 story? Are we even allowed to allude to the Photoshop? I guess most people probably don't know what that means. But, yes, the Photoshop 4 story. Oh, my God. It's up to Sean.
其中一个，我当时就想，天哪。哪一个？Photoshop 4 的故事？我们甚至被允许提到 Photoshop 吗？我想大多数人可能不知道那意味着什么。但是，是的，Photoshop 4 的故事。天哪。这得看 Sean 的意思。
We're not, it's totally, you know, there are a number of stories that have to be at the bar or in a non-recorded environment. Not necessarily out of bar, folks. But anyways, we were going to record last night. Dinner went a little bit too long. Thank you to Florist Bob, who organized our dinner. We have these wonderful Nvidia developer tags that we've been given out in addition to the ADSP stickers.
我们不是，这完全是，你知道，有很多故事必须在酒吧或非录音环境下讲。不一定非要在酒吧，伙计们。但无论如何，我们本来打算昨晚录制的。晚餐时间太长了。感谢组织我们晚餐的 Florist Bob。除了 ADSP 贴纸外，我们还有这些很棒的英伟达开发者标签。
And I took a couple extra ones. So if you find me at a C++ event for maybe the next six months, I'll probably have a couple. Yep. We gave out a lot of stickers, folks. And should we do initial thoughts on C++? plus under the C-2025, or should we just start? Let's do some initial thoughts.
我多拿了几个。所以如果你在接下来的六个月里在某个 C++ 活动上找到我，我可能还有几个。是的。我们发了很多贴纸，伙计们。我们应该先谈谈对 C++ Under the Sea 2025 的初步想法，还是直接开始？让我们先谈谈初步想法。
What did you think? Great conference or greatest conference ever? Well, it's not the greatest conference ever. You know, now you got me thinking what's the greatest conference I've ever been to. Hey, Ray. Ray. We were just, we were just going to recap our thoughts on the conference. I was, I was asking.
你觉得怎么样？很棒的会议还是有史以来最棒的会议？嗯，它不是有史以来最棒的会议。你知道，现在你让我开始思考我参加过的最棒的会议是什么了。嘿，Ray。Ray。我们刚才正要回顾一下对会议的想法。我当时在问。
What did I ask? You asked, because I was like, oh, let's give initial thoughts on how the conference went. And he's like, was it greatest conference ever? And I was like, well, no, it's not that great? Or the greatest conference ever? It was great. Not the greatest, and that doesn't mean it's not a bad conference. All right, we should introduce Ray.
我问了什么？你问了，因为我当时说，哦，让我们谈谈对会议进展的初步想法。然后他说，这是有史以来最棒的会议吗？我就说，嗯，不，它没那么棒？还是有史以来最棒的会议？它很棒。不是最棒的，但这并不意味着它不是一个糟糕的会议。好吧，我们应该介绍一下 Ray。
But we got Ray, fellow Invidian folks. Yes, Ray. He contacts us via email both with our Nvidia emails and my personal. I'm not sure if he emails you personally. But Ray, introduce yourself. Hi, I'm Ray. I'm one of the co-organizers of this conference. Yeah, for me, it was the best one so far.
我们有 Ray，英伟达的同事。是的，Ray。他通过电子邮件联系我们，既用我们的英伟达邮箱，也用我的个人邮箱。我不确定他是否私下给你发邮件。但 Ray，介绍一下你自己。嗨，我是 Ray。我是这次会议的共同组织者之一。是的，对我来说，这是目前为止最棒的一次。
And what do you? What do you? Definitely was the best C++ under the C. I think it was the best C++ under the C. Yeah, yeah, for sure. And what do you do at InVidio? I work in a team in the Netherlands, which is also where I'm from. I work on cluster management software.
那你呢？你呢？绝对是最好的 C++ Under the Sea。我认为这是最好的 C++ Under the Sea。是的，是的，肯定的。你在英伟达做什么？我在荷兰的一个团队工作，这也是我的家乡。我从事集群管理软件的工作。
It's called BCM, base command manager. And, yeah, there I do a mix of C++, Python, but also Kubernetes. Oh, Kubernetes. The scary word here. We talk about all the programming languages, but as soon as somebody says the DevOps words, we run for the hills, folks. We run for the hills. Yes, we do.
它叫 BCM，基础命令管理器。是的，我在那里做 C++、Python 和 Kubernetes 的混合工作。哦，Kubernetes。这里可怕的词。我们谈论所有的编程语言，但一旦有人提到 DevOps 的词，我们就逃之夭夭了，伙计们。我们逃之夭夭。是的，我们确实。
Do you work with the people? who do DCGM? No, but my integration with my knowledge of DCGM is the perspective from our product is we collect those metrics. Okay, okay, okay.
你和做 DCGM 的人一起工作吗？不，但我对 DCGM 的了解是通过我们产品的视角，我们收集那些指标。好的，好的，好的。
So how did this conference come to be, Ray? What was your vision or what was the organizer's vision? Yeah, this is a spin-off from the meetup group that I've been running since 2013 already. And I met Hans, who was the main organizer, and Andrew, who is also a co-organizer,
那么这次会议是怎么来的，Ray？你的愿景或组织者的愿景是什么？是的，这是我自 2013 年以来一直在运营的聚会小组的衍生项目。我遇到了 Hans，他是主要组织者，还有 Andrew，他也是共同组织者，
at various of these meetups. And Hans had the idea to organize a conference for a long time, and that's how it all started. All right, all right. We're going to each do two things that we learned at this conference, and you two are going to go first while I try to remember what I learned. Oh, what I learned? Yeah, two things you learned.
在这些聚会上。Hans 很早就有了组织会议的想法，这就是一切的开始。好的，好的。我们每个人都要说两件我们在这次会议上学到的事情，你们两个先来，我试着回忆一下我学到了什么。哦，我学到了什么？是的，你学到的两件事。
A lot of things. So they don't come to mind. in an order of... The first two that come to mind. They don't have to be the most important. I have never thought about generic programming applied to higher level things like Sean was discussing in his keynote.
很多事情。所以它们没有按顺序出现在脑海里……首先想到的两件事。它们不必是最重要的。我从未想过将泛型编程应用于 Sean 在主题演讲中讨论的那种更高级别的事物。
That was... Yeah, I'm still processing that, to be honest. And little things, like new features in C++ Plus 23, like maybe I've not been keeping up well enough, but like SDD ignore or bind left. That's kind of... Bind Left, was it? Yeah.
那是……是的，老实说，我还在消化。还有一些小事，比如 C++ 23 中的新特性，也许我跟进得不够好，但比如 std::ignore 或 bind_left。那是……Bind Left，是吗？是的。
Yeah, those kind of... trivial things come to mind that I simply didn't know about them and yeah yeah I don't know more things may come to mind but I learned so the coolest thing I saw there was a talk from some of the Conan folks
是的，那种……琐碎的事情浮现在脑海中，我只是不知道它们，是的，是的，我不知道，可能会想到更多的事情，但我学到了，我在那里看到的最酷的事情是来自 Conan 的一些人的演讲
about using Conan to install CUDA and using Conan and C-MIC to install CUDA and work with CUDA and the thing that I saw that was very very cool was they have this support for cross-building where you can do
关于使用 Conan 安装 CUDA，以及使用 Conan 和 CMake 安装 CUDA 并使用 CUDA，我看到的最酷的事情是他们支持交叉构建，你可以在你的服务器上进行构建，然后他们有一个小小的 CMake 工具，它可以计算出需要复制到嵌入式设备的文件，把它们复制过去，然后远程运行 CTest，所以你不必去弄清楚这些，他们可以做到这一点，因为他们是包管理器，他们知道所有的依赖项是什么，我觉得这超级酷，不仅仅是人们在英伟达 Jetson 上进行嵌入式开发，而是人们在进行一般的嵌入式开发，嗯，是的，这就是我学到的，嗯，Connor 抛弃了我们去买点吃的，因为他很饿
the build on your server and then they've got this like little c make tool where it will figure out what files it needs to copy over to the embedded device copy them over there and then run c test remotely so you don't have to figure that out and they can do that because they're the package manager they know what all the dependencies are and i thought that was super cool not just people doing an embedded development on invidia jetson but people doing embedded development in general and uh yeah that was what i learned and uh Connor has abandoned us to go get some food because he's very hungry
因为他不喜欢某些东西，不喜欢奶油或质地奇怪的食物，他在食物方面有点挑剔，所以他在午餐时选择有限。我其实也从你的演讲中学到了很多，现在想起来了，所以我根本不是 CUDA 专家，但我几年前玩过它，我记得语法
because he doesn't like certain doesn't like creams or like foods with textures he's a little bit picky about food and so he's he had limited options at lunch I actually I actually also learned a lot from your talk comes to mind now so I'm not a Akuta expert at all but I've been playing around with it like a couple years ago and I remember syntax
比如三个小于号。是的，是的，是的，尖括号启动，三重尖括号内核启动。那些东西肯定消失很久了，还有更多的库支持。它实际上让我想再次尝试它，即使我不必这样做，是的。你应该尝试。我的意思是，你知道，人们认为英伟达的每个人都做 CUDA，做 GPU 的东西，但实际上英伟达有很多做其他事情的人。做基础设施的东西，做核心
like three less than character. Yeah, yeah, yeah, the Chevron launch, the triple Chevron kernel launch. Those kind of things are away for a long time, I'm sure, and so much more library support. It actually makes me want to play with it again, even though I don't have to, yeah. You should. I mean, it's, you know, people assume that everybody at NVIDIA does Kuda, does GPU stuff, but actually there's a lot of people in Vitiya that do other sorts of things. It does infrastructure stuff, does the core
库，核心软件。你们团队怎么样？你们使用什么样的 C++ 方言？你们使用的 C++ 代码有多现代？比如是什么？你说有一些 Python。比如，你知道，处理 C++ 和 Python 的交叉是什么感觉？
libraries, core software. What's it like in your team? Like what sort of C++ dialects do you use? How modern is the C++ code that you use? Like what's it? You said there's some Python. Like, you know, what's it like dealing with the C++ Python crossover?
是的，Python 和 C++ 之间的边界是通过 API。所以，是的，我们的核心产品，运行在旧服务器上的产品，是用 C++ 编写的，以保持相对较小的占用空间。我们目前使用的是 C++17，我相信，
Yeah, the boundary between Python and C++ plus is through APIs. So, yeah, our core product, the product that runs on old servers, is written in C++ to have a reason reasonably smaller footprint. We use, I believe, currently C++17,
可能很快会跳到 20。所以它是现代和一些旧部分的混合。所以，是的，我们尽量保持更新。这个产品已经存在一段时间了。我看到 Connor 回来了。那么 Connor。好吧，我确实买了一些吃的，我决定换掉我之前吃的四个鸡块，
and probably soon will jump to 20. So it's a mix of modern and some older parts. So, yeah, we try to keep it up to date. It's been around for a while, this product. I see Connor's coming back. So Connor. Well, I did get some food, and I decided to change up the nugget that I had four of earlier,
结果是一个奶酪味的。我刚才还在告诉大家你对食物有多挑剔，你真是个小公主。都在那儿了。哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，如果我们非要用“公主”这个词，那也只能用在你身上，伙计。我有点挑剔，而且每一个三明治里都有奶酪。
and it ended up being a cheese one. I was just telling people how picky What a little princess you are with the food It's all in there Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, if we're going to throw the word princess around It only is applied to you, buddy I'm a little bit particular And every one of the sandwiches had cheese on them
它们看起来不错，只是我不喜欢奶酪。这不是会议的问题，这是我的问题。我们刚才问的问题是什么？你在会议上学到的前两件事是什么？我只说了一件，但我不知道人们是否注意到了，因为我的回答太好了。所以，我不确定这算不算。这是我学到的东西，但我会把它作为我的答案。
They look good, just don't like cheese It's not a problem with the conference, this is a problem with me What was the question we were asking? What were the top two things you learned at the conference? I only gave one, but I don't know if people noticed that Because my answer is so good. So, I'm not sure if this counts It's something I learned, but I will be saying it as my answer
我现在正在思考，我们有哥本哈根之行的第二部分，然后是我们之前在 NDC 进行的对话的一到两部分，然后我们之后录制了最后一次吗？是的，我们和 Vittorio 以及 J.F 录制了，所以至少有一、二、三集，最少
and I'm trying to think right now we've got part two of walking in Copenhagen then there's going to be one or two parts from the conversation that we had at NDC and then did we record a final time afterwards yeah we did with Vittorio and with J.F so that is at least one, two, three minimum episodes
也许四集，这把我们带到了十一月。所以当你在听这个的时候，听众，我要么正在结婚，要么在度蜜月。重点是，这已经是过去式了，我期待已久的、我们一直没能谈论的、我一直在给 Bryce 消音的库已经在 C++ Under the Sea 上发布了。它叫 Parrot。它是目前市面上最好的 C++ 体验。
maybe four which brings us into November so while you were listening to this listener I am either getting married or on my honeymoon. And the point being is that it is much in the past, and my long-awaited library that we haven't been able to talk about that I was bleeping Bryce out has been released at C++ Under the Sea. It's called Parrot. It's the best C++ experience out there.
这个库的图形标识是一只鹦鹉。Kuhn，我告诉他跟着我，但他消失了，他在这次会议上问我，这只鹦鹉有名字吗？我说，不，它没有名字。他说，好吧，你应该叫这只鹦鹉 Sean Parrot。那是……Sean 就在我们旁边。
And the graphic signifier for the library is a parrot. And Coon, who I told to follow me, but then he disappeared, said to me, while I was at this conference, he asked, does the parrot have a name? And I said, no, it does not have a name. He's like, well, you should call the parrot Sean Parrot. And that is... Sean's right next to us.
他听到了 Sean Parrot。他只是抬头看了看。我的意思是，他完全批准了。我从外部贡献者那里合并的第一个拉取请求来自 Kuhn，他创建了一个分支，并将自述文件中图像的替代文本重命名为 Sean Parrot。所以这只鹦鹉的正式名字是 Sean Parrot。
And he heard Sean Parrott. And he just looked up. I mean, he's fully approved. And the first pull request that I merged from an external contributor was from Kuhn, who he created a fork, and he renamed the alt text on the image in the readme to be Sean Parrott. So officially the name of the parrot is Sean Parrot.
我对此感到非常激动。我觉得你把故事讲砸了，因为他第一次建议的时候。他只是说，哦，你应该叫这只鹦鹉 Sean。不，不。所以他确实说了 Sean Parrot，但我只听到了 Sean 和 it，或者可能我听到了 parent。我当时想，好吧，我的意思是，这有点太直白了。我明白了。就像他启发了我走上算法之旅等等。
And I am thrilled about this. I feel like you flubbed the story a little bit because the first time he suggested it. He's just said, oh, you should call the parrot Sean. No, no. So he did say Sean Parrot, but I only heard Sean and it, or like maybe I heard parent. And I was like, well, I mean, it's a little on the nose. I get it. Like he's inspired me down the algorithm journey, et cetera.
但他第二次告诉我。然后我才意识到，哦，你说的是 Sean Parrot。然后，每个人都大笑起来，我们当时说，这是我在这里听到的最好的建议或事情。所以这是我学到的东西吗？不完全是。但它是官方的东西。它是传说的一部分。另一件事，我学到的第二件事是你的贡献，即添加了 std::integral_constant 以避免 Softmax 示例中的模板问题。
But he told me a second time. And then that was when I was like, oh, you're saying Sean Parrott. And then, like, everyone burst out laughing, and we were like, that's the best suggestion or thing I've been told in here. So is it something I learned? Not really. But it is something that is official. It's a part of the lore. Another thing, the actual, another second thing that I learned was your contribution in terms of adding the stood integral constant in order to avoid the template issue with the Softmax example.
这正是 Softmax 不在函数中的原因。因为我知道可能有一个解决方案，无论是把它变成一个运行时参数。我甚至不知道 integral_constant 运行时参数。我们应该解释这个技巧。如果你有一个模板参数，一个像 int 一样的非类型模板参数，就像你有一个函数，它接受一个 C++ 函数，该函数接受一个 int 作为模板参数，如果它是一个成员函数。比如如果 std::tuple 有一个成员函数 get，
And that is exactly why Softmax wasn't in a function. Because I knew that there was probably a solution, whether it was just making it a runtime parameter. I didn't even know about the integral constant runtime parameter. We should explain this trick. If you have a template parameter, a non-type template parameter that's like an int, like you have a function that takes a C++ function that takes an end as a template parameter, if it's, for example, a member function. Like if Stood Tupil had a member function Git,
那么如果你正在使用，如果你正在使用那个模板，在它依赖的上下文中。比如如果你正在做，你知道，你有一些元组作为模板参数，然后你做了像 T.get，其中 get 是一个接受整数模板参数的模板函数。你必须在点后面加上 template 这个词
then if you were using the, if you're using that template, in a context where it's dependent. Like if you were doing like, you know, you had some tuple that you took as a template parameter and then you did like T. Dot Git, where Git was a template function that took an integral template parameter. You have to put the word template after the dot
这样它就不会有歧义，这太糟糕了。所以绕过这个的一个技巧是你可以使用用户定义的字面量，这样你可以添加一个用户定义的字面量，比如 _IC，它会返回一个 integral_constant 对象，然后你可以更改你的模板以添加一个额外的函数参数，不是模板参数，而是函数参数
so it's not ambiguous, which is awful. And so one trick to get around this is that you can use user-defined literals so you can add a user to find literal like underscore IC that will return an integral constant object and then you can change your template to add an additional function parameter, not a template parameter, but a function parameter
它是一个 integral_constant，从中可以推导出你的非类型模板参数。你可以直接默认那个函数参数，这样现有的 API 可以继续工作，但人们可以使用的好的 API 是他们可以做，你知道，get(1_IC)，而不是必须做 get()。
that is an integral constant from which your non-type template parameter can be deduced. And you can just default that function parameter so that the existing API continues to work but then the nice API that people can do is they can do, you know, dot get, open prins, like one underscore IC, close prins, instead of having to do the dot template, get, you know, angle brackets, one, close angle brackets, open print, close print.
这就是我向 Connor 建议的事情，Connor 很快就把它写出来了。指南编码，指南编码。我做了。看，有区别。vibe coding 你不检查，guide coding 你肯定会检查，但这是一个绝妙的建议。它仍然有点丑，我不喜欢 _IC，但它比那个好一个数量级，人们可能没有遇到过这种情况，但我以前遇到过这种代码，你必须做一个点，所以你原来的函数会是你的 a.b，然后你的，呃，尖括号，你知道，用你的，你知道，整数，在我的例子中，所以它是
And so that was the thing I suggested to Connor, and Connor went off and vibe coded it very quickly. A guide coded it, guide coded it. I did. Look, there's a difference. vibe coding you don't look guide coding you definitely check but it was a brilliant suggestion it's still a little bit ugly i don't love the underscore i see but it is an order of magnitude better than the and people might have not encountered this but i had encountered this kind of code before where you have to do a dot so your original function would be like your a dot b and then your uh chevron you know with your you know uh integer in my case so it's angle one end angle
然后是你的括号。相反，你必须写 a.template B()，这太糟糕了。以至于我没有把 Softmax 放在函数里，我当时想，我们会处理这个，我们会把这个问题推迟。现在我们正在接近 Sean。他一直，哦，他有一个备份。他一直，他是一个受欢迎的人。
and then your parence. Instead, you have to go a dot template, space, B, and then your angle, angle, and paren, paren, which is just awful. It's so much so that I didn't put softmax in a function, and I was like, we'll deal with this, we'll kick this down the road. And now we're approaching Sean. He's been, oh, he got a backup. He's been, he's a popular guy.
Sean 今天被要求签名，他签了 EOP 编程元素那本书吗？他签了。我被要求签过名，这是一种有趣的经历。是的。所以无论如何，这就是 Sean Parrot。
Sean was being asked for his autograph today, and he signed the, EOP elements of programming book? He did. I've been asked to sign stuff, and it is an interesting experience. Yep. So anyways, that's Sean Parrott.
这是这次会议对我来说最突出的第一点。而且，我的意思是，在这一点上，其实我们不应该谈论鹦鹉以前的颜色。我的意思是，其实我们可以谈谈。有一次，在鹦鹉变成 Sean Parrot 之前，Sean Parrot 是粉红色的。我也提交了一个问题，鹦鹉应该是绿色的。是的，它应该是英伟达绿。
Number one highlighted this conference for me. And, I mean, also, too, at this point, actually, we shouldn't talk about the former color of the parrot. I mean, actually, we can talk about it. At one point, Sean Parrot was pink before the Parrot was Sean Parrott. I filed an issue, too, that the parrot should be green. Yeah, it should be the Invidia Green.
所以我们已经改变了它。我们刚刚突破了 100 个星标。在这一点上，在十一月的这个时候，我希望我们已经突破了 1,000 个。可能不会，但这是充满希望的想法。而且，我也会发布我今天演讲的 YouTube 版本。在某个时候，可能最早是周一，
So we have changed that. and we just crossed 100 stars. At this point, at this point in November, I'm hoping we've crossed 1,000. Probably not, but it's hopeful thinking. And also, too, I will have given a YouTube version of the talk that I present today. At some point, it might be as soon as Monday,
但也可能是一周半之后。无论如何，当这个播客播出时，它已经是过去式了。所以如果你还没看过，节目说明里有链接。你好，听众。我录制这段插曲时是 10 月 30 日。你可能是在 11 月 14 日星期五听到的，
but it might be a week and a half later. Regardless, though, it'll be in the past from when this is airing on our podcast. So link in the show notes, if you haven't seen that already. Hello, listener. It is October 30th when I am recording this interruption. And you are potentially listening to this on Friday, November 14th,
或者在这之后的几天或几周。我没有发布我所说的 YouTube 视频。但是，我发布了一个提到 Parrot 的 YouTube 视频。它不完全是关于 Parrot 的，但它将 Parrot 与其他几个 Python 和 C++ 库进行了比较。所以节目说明里有链接。如果你恰好在 11 月 14 日发布后的两到三周内听到这个，那个演讲可能在那时已经发布了。
or a few days or a couple weeks after this. I have not released the YouTube video that I said I would. However, I have released a YouTube video that mentions Parrot. It's not fully about Parrot, but it compares Parrot to a couple other Python and C++ libraries. So link in the show notes for that. And if you do happen to be listening to this on a bit of a delay, two to three weeks after this is released on November 14th. That talk may have been released at that point.
所以我会在节目说明中留下一个未链接的链接，一旦它发布，我们就会链接它。所以一定要查看节目说明，了解那个演讲何时可用。而且，嘿，Paul，你想打个招呼吗？嘿，Paul。Paul 是另一个在英伟达工作的人。我们和很多英伟达的人一起吃了晚饭，我不记得名字了，Wolfus，Wolfsar。Wolf 就像你，你在英伟达工作了
So I will leave a unlinked link in the show notes and we'll link it as soon as it has been released. So just be sure to check the show notes for when that talk does become available. And, uh, hey, Paul, you want to say hi? Hey, Paul. Paul's another person who works at NVIDIA. There's a lot of NVIDIA we had dinner with at, I don't remember the name, Wolfus, Wolfsar. Wolf's like you You work at Nvidia for like
再过两天。Paul 不在英伟达工作了。是的，他不在这儿工作了。是的，抱歉 Paul。他是一个实习生。哦，等等，你还在工作到午夜吗？是的，Paul 是实习生。
Two more days Paul doesn't work at Nvidia anymore Yeah no he doesn't work at Nvidia anymore Yeah sorry Paul He was an in Oh wait are you still employed until like midnight? Yeah Paul is an intern
我们夏天有一个很棒的实习生。今天是他的最后一天。但他会回来的。明年年初某个时候。是的，全职。告诉我们你的实习经历。告诉我们关于你自己的事。希望你回来全职。
Great intern we had over the summer Today is his last day But then he'll be coming back Sometime early next year Yeah for full time Tell us about your internship Tell us about yourself Hopefully you're coming back full time
听众，我知道那个问题的答案。我只是在给他们设套。哦，这很棒，很棒的经历。我真的很期待，因为我在实习期间一直在使用 CCCL。甚至在你在这里工作之前。是的，是的。这就是你在英伟达找到工作的方式，伙计们。你必须每天使用它并成为专家。是的，我甚至一直在教授基于 Thrust 的课程，教人们 Thrust。使用它或贡献，为我们主要的开源产品做出贡献。如果你想在英伟达被录用，这是一个被注意到的好方法。我的意思是，现在招聘非常紧张，请不要发邮件给我，是的，你是一个存在的证明。
Listener I know the answer to that question I'm just setting them up Oh, it was great, great experience. I was really looking forward to it because I've been using the CCCL where I had my internship for a long time. Even before you were working here. Yeah, yeah. That's how you get a job at Nvidia, folks. You've got to be using it on the daily and become an expert. Yeah, I've been even teaching courses based on thrust, teaching people's thrust. Using it or contributing, contributing to our major open source products. Great way to get noticed if you want to get hired at NVIDIA. I mean hiring very tight right now please no emails work for me yeah you're an existence proof
所以你在那之前就在使用它，然后你被录用为实习生，所以你在这里待了四个月，八个月，三个月，3.8 个月，好的，今天是你的最后一天，确切地说，明白了，所以你要回去休息一段时间，回去上学，我们正在完成我的学校，是的，不管那意味着什么。哦，该死。搅拌棒，你在哪儿弄到的？我只是……对于听众来说，那个小插曲，
so you're using it before then you got hiders an intern so you've been here for four months eight months three months three point eight okay and today was your is your last day exactly gotcha and so you're going back taking some time off going back to school we are finishing my uh my school yeah whatever that means. Oh, shit. The muddler, where'd you get those? I just... For the listener, that little diversion there,
我们又获得了一些饮料代币，所以期待接下来的时间。这会很有趣。Sean 被逼到角落了。但我们现在在和 Paul 谈话，所以你要完成学业，休息一段时间，然后你什么时候开始？
we've acquired some more drink tokens, so expect the next however bit. It's going to be fun. Sean's been cornered. But we're talking to Paul now, so you're finishing your school, taking a little bit of time off, and then when do you start?
你要加入同一个团队吗？是的，二月份我将重新加入 CCCL 团队。并继续从事并行算法的工作，这基本上是我的梦想工作。那么并行算法，你最喜欢哪一个？我们不再问这个问题了。我们已经失去了与根源的联系。你最喜欢的算法是什么？
Are you joining the same team? Yeah, in February I will rejoin the CCCL team. and keep working on parallel algorithms, which is basically my dream job. So parallel algorithms, what's your favorite? We don't ask this question anymore. We've lost touch with our roots. What is your favorite algorithm?
并行，串行，没关系。开始。我的意思是，问题是我作为你播客的追随者已经知道答案了。等等，没有，这是你最喜欢的算法。你怎么能……不，因为我认为我们最初的答案是归约，但我认为我的答案已经变了。
Parallel, cereal, it doesn't matter. Go. I mean, the problem is I already know the answer as a follower of your podcast. Wait, there is no, it's your favorite algorithm. How can you... No, because I think our original answer was reductions, but I think my answer has changed.
我的答案绝对是扫描。这是一个私人的事情，对吧？当然是扫描。是的。是的。哪个扫描？我们有几个扫描。解耦回溯扫描，自然。
My answer is definitely scanned. It's a personal thing, right? It's certainly scan. Yeah. Yeah. Which scan? We got a couple scans. DeCouple look back scan, naturally.
包含扫描是……我假设你读过 Dwayne Merrill 的论文。我们最初是不是说归约？绝对是，是的。我想我们最初说的是归约。或者我最初说的是归约。变换归约是我最喜欢的。是的。
The inclusive scan is... I assume you read the Dwayne Meryl paper. Did we originally say Reduce? Absolutely, yeah. I think we originally said Reduce. Or I originally said Reduce. Transform Reduce is my favorite. Yes.
但那已经变了，伙计们。现在我是“扫描侠”。一切都是关于扫描。你最喜欢的扫描应用是什么？我要插入，你知道那个 Scatman 吗？我是 Scatman。啦，啦，啦，啦，啦。我是 Scatman。
But that's changed, folks. Now I'm a scan man. It's all about the scan. What's your favorite application of scan? I'm going to insert, do you know the Scatman? I'm the Scatman. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I'm a scatman.
我要剪掉那个，我要把它加进去。“扫描侠”。这就是你应该被称为的名字。Bryce，“扫描侠”，Adelstein Lelbeck。是的。我的意思是，对于我的博士论文，我一直在研究稀疏线性代数，那里有很多扫描的应用，因为有时，例如，你知道你矩阵的每一行有多少个元素，
I'm going to cut that, I'm going to club that in. The Scan Man. That is what you should be known as. Bryce, the Scan Man, Adelstein Lelbeck. Yes. I mean, for my PhD thesis, I've been working on sparse linear algebra, and there's lots of applications for scans there, because sometimes, for example, you know how many elements you have in each row of your matrix,
然后通过扫描，你可以得到内存中的偏移量。我们今天早些时候还在谈论扫描在稀疏线性代数中的应用。你要拿着这个。你像那样在那边谈论它。好吧，这是你的工作。
and then with the scan, you can get the offset into memory. for that. We were just talking earlier today about applications of scans and sparse linear algebra. You're going to hold this. You're talking it over there like that. Well, it's your job.
我在这儿喝酒。我正在喝我的……每个人都在喝酒。而你只是……无论如何。好的。但是是的，我们今天早些时候还在谈论如何实现
I'm drinking here. I'm drinking my... Everybody's drinking. And you're just... Anyway. Okay. But yeah, we were just talking earlier today about how to implement
这个新的 CUDA 东西中的某些稀疏线性代数技术。我们当时在谈论扫描在那里的潜在用途，是的，但我最近最喜欢的扫描是这些，这些，这些，像，呃，我的单调变换扫描，你有一个扫描，它既接受一个变换迭代器作为输入，又接受一个变换输出迭代器，嗯，而且我们，我不想，我不想剧透任何东西，但我们谈到了它的一个应用
certain sparse linear algebra techniques in this new coup tile thing. And we were talking about the potential uses of scans there and yeah but my my uh my favorite recent scans have been these these uh these uh like uh um myenoidal transformation scans where you have a scan that takes both a transform iterator as the input and then a transform output iterator um and uh we that we i don't want to i don't want to spoil anything but we talked about one application to that
对于比例跟踪器，我想我们在播客中谈到了这一点，是的，是的，我们谈到了。但在哥本哈根，我们谈到了游程解码，你确信它不能在单次传递中完成，伙计们。让我告诉你，哦，它很美。它很美。单次传递游程解码，我们将看看它。我们将在，我不知道，到那时是十二月，
for the proportional tracker i think we talked about that in the podcast yes yes we did but But we talked in Copenhagen about run-length decode, and you were convinced it couldn't be done in a single-passing, folks. Let me tell you, oh, it's beautiful. It's beautiful. The single-passed run-length decoding, and we're going to look at it. We're going to look at it in, I don't know, December at this point,
因为我们有太多的剧集积压。但下次我们，像，回家，录制时，我们会看看那个。它很美。等等，所以你在谈论解耦回溯，也就是 Dwayne Merrill，我想是 Michael Garland 的合著者。在那篇论文上。是的。
because we've got such a backlog of episodes. But the next time we're, like, home, and recording, we're going to look at that. It's beautiful. Wait, so you're talking about decoupled look-back, aka Dwayne Merrill, I think Michael Garland's co-author. on that paper. Yeah.
你还有其他的吗？因为当你说是“扫描侠”时，我脑子里有个小声音说，嗯，严格来说 Mark Harris 应该是“扫描侠”。如果有人是“扫描侠”，那就是 Mark Harris，他是英伟达的员工。他写过许多有影响力的论文。其中之一是前缀和及其应用，我想是这个标题。模数可能是一个或两个词。我得去弄点吃的。
And do you have other? Because when you said scan man, there was a little voice in my head being like, well, technically Mark Harris should be the scan man. If there's anybody that's the scan man, it's Mark Harris, who is an employee of NVIDIA. He's written many influential papers. One of them being prefix sums and their applications, I think, is the title. Modulo may be a word or two. I got to go get some of that food.
好的，Bryce 要去买点吃的了。我假设你读过，如果你读过解耦回溯，那是一篇比其他论文更棘手的论文。你有论文或资源给那些想成为像你一样的扫描专家的人吗？也许扫描少一点，但有英伟达点播网站，你可以看到旧 GTC 的所有旧演讲。而且我认为，例如，有一个关于如何实现基数排序或优化它的演讲。那个非常有趣。
All right, Bryce is leaving to go get some food. I assume you've read the, if you've read the decoupled look bad, that's a trickier paper than the others. Do you have papers or? resources for people that want to become scan experts like yourself? Maybe less scan, but there's the Nvidia on Demand website where you can see all the old talks from old GTCs. And I think there's, for example, a talk on how to implement Radex sort or optimize it. That one was very interesting.
不是要让你当场出丑，但你是如何实现基数排序的？我的意思是，肯定涉及扫描。一定要查看这些节目说明，在你的播客中和/或在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。这不是口号。我们的口号是充满信息点缀的混乱。来自 C++ Under the Sea 2025，伙计们。
Not to put you on the spot, but how do you implement RADXSort? I mean, there are certainly scans involved. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast and or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. Live from C++ under the C. 2025, folks.
音频水平正确吗？我们不知道。这是我们最后一次采访他吗？亲自？不，只是通常情况下。你脸上全是奶酪，兄弟。我的意思是，还有什么新鲜事吗？你听起来不像我女朋友。别那样跟我说。
Is the audio levels correct? We don't know. Is this the last time we interviewed him? In person? No, just in general. You got cheese all over your face, bro. I mean, what else is new? Don't you sound like my girlfriend. Don't tell me that.
你说的最后一次采访他是什么意思？我们最后一次采访他不是两个月前吗？哦，是的，没错。没错。我完全忘了。那正在进行。我的脸颊塞满了……好的。
What do you mean the last time we interviewed him? And where's the last time we interviewed him like two months ago? Oh, yeah, that's right. That's right. I totally forgot. That's going. My cheeks filled with a... All right.
好的，我明白了。我们要去哪儿？不，不，我们只是站一会儿。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
Okay, I understand. Where are we going? No, no, we're just standing in for a second. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，我明白了。我们要去哪儿？不，不，我们只是站一会儿。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。